in anime most
memories of it are of heroes emerging
triumphant with their nifty new skill
often followed by a speech about their
training friends or whatnot however what
a lot of people tend to forget is that
an anime series is a long
developing narrative and to get to that
point our characters have to go through
a lot
and when i say a lot i mean a lot in
order for the glorious rise of the hero
often he'll typically have to get
knocked down a peg first
you see prior to some of the most
climactic moments in anime history
is that defining moment where the heroes
at his lowest now without further ado
here are 10 moments where the anime
protagonists get destroyed
gone taking on hanzo makes it as the
first entry on this list
quite early on in the series gone has
managed to make his way past the
previous trails in the hunter exam
with the final phase of the exam at hand
gone finds himself facing hanzo opening
the final phase with the battle where
the only way to win is to force your
opponent to admit defeat
gone has a tough match ahead of him and
just as expected he gets roughed up and
beaten down systematically by the
opponent that's much stronger faster and
superior in
every single way gone realistically
never had a chance and the only weapon
that he gets left with
is his indomitable heart and guts even
after enduring this beating gone refuses
to give up and admit defeat
coming to light gone for his spirit
hanzo eventually surrenders on his own
but out of a sense of admiration not the
most convincing way to win for a lot but
the fight does show us how strong gone's
fortitude is so with a heart like that
challenges can be overcome at least
that's what i think the message of that
episode is anyway it also sets the
foundation for what defines gone and
makes some moments in the future arcs a
lot more stronger and more impactful
at number nine we take a look at ichigo
versus okiyora
personally speaking i was torn between
featuring this fight or the first fight
against eisen while the iso one was more
memorable
i think that'd be a good idea to feature
the fight against all kia or more since
it's not as popular and the fact that
the fourth espada would go on to have
more fights against ichigo and end up
mopping the floor with him each and
every time the two had their first
encounter right at the start of the
arunkar
arc and all kiyora already made a big
impression through his demeanor and
supposed strength over his companion
yami
the tenth the spider who made quick work
of ichigo fast forward later and we get
their first actual fight
and things didn't go too well for ichigo
luckily for him though grimjan was
around to bring orihime for some much
needed healing
even their final confrontation where
ulcera unveils his numerous forms saw
ichigo get stomped for ninety percent of
the fight
first impressions do matter and the
first encounter where alkiora puts
ichigo to the brink of death
really made one mighty impression
next is araragi vs kanbaru remember back
when rainy devil attempted to fill
komburu's wish forget putting up a fight
as we saw there's just virtually no way
to act and follow the beat of ganbaru's
relentless assault koyomi just got
massacred and there's no other way to
put it koyomi got ripped apart so
brutally that the whole thing had to be
censored
seriously without the special palette
that the anime used i'm sure the fight
would have seemed a lot more brutal than
what we usually see from brutal fights
in anime before but seeing someone get
thrown around by the intestines not
exactly the most beautiful sight now is
it censorship aside the anime pulled no
punches in depicting the battle the best
way it can with its blazing fast visuals
that make you feel the impact of each of
ganbaru's attacks
totally not what you'd expect of a show
after spending hours searching for memes
thanks to ray nice circulation huh
want to make a new antagonist group as
menacing and memorable
have them make an impact by outright
killing one of the main protagonists in
a series where there are so many
overpowered characters like seven deadly
sins
such a feat would be almost unimaginable
but boy
did the ten commandments do it to be
fair though it probably isn't the best
idea for meliodas to take on the entire
group by himself on the other hand he
prepared for droll and gloccinia not the
entire squad
so i digress it's a one-man army fight
waiting to happen but unfortunately for
meliodas he's not fighting no-name
underlings or anything like that the
numbers game quickly catches up despite
how overpowered meliodas is
and he finds himself succumbing to the
combined might of the commandments it
all ends in a spectacular fashion with
meliodas getting stabbed and dying
and this isn't the last time we see
meliotis in the series for obvious
reasons but it's a moment that marks a
huge shift in the balance of power in
the series
as if attack on titan at this point
hasn't already made it clear that it's a
show that dares to do away with shonen
anime cliches and narratives we
immediately get treated to this fight a
typical anime fan would expect aaron to
charge in a fit of rage as a titan after
seeing multiple people die and i'm sure
that most fans would have expected aaron
to come out victorious
therefore ending the ark right there
well one titan did get stomped
but it's eren to be fair aaron does put
up a fight
but he was ultimately no match against
the female titan who makes quick work of
him and pulls him out of his titan form
fortunately for him though he was spared
from much of the pain coming his way by
his fellow humans
after reeling from the defeat aaron gets
a chance to regroup and prepare to fight
for another day
this time he'll make sure to deal with
the female titan for good but that
battle is probably best talked about
some other day
[Music]
next we have subaru's first few battles
against elsa
in re-zero who could forget the first
time we got a glimpse of subaru's powers
normally that line would be reserved for
someone unleashing pent-up power and
stomping an opponent
unfortunately for our lucky isakai
protagonist here his power activates
when he dies yeah not the most
convenient ability out there now is it
being able to go back to a checkpoint
and write what you did wrong sounds good
but having to experience death in the
most gruesome ways to do it
i don't think so no thanks the second
round with felt in tow is more of a
fight
but we're then treated to a showcase of
just how much stronger a trained
assassin is even with felt an old man
rom's help subaru quickly dies another
death
proving that he's ultimately just as
helpless as he thought he was
then again it's the interesting ability
and helplessness that played a big part
in re zero becoming the smash hit
subversion of the standard isakai tropes
in shows in the genre
luffy's well known for your
quintessential mould of a classic shonen
protagonist outrageous dreams
a knack for adventure and a firm
believer of the power of bonds another
trait is his ability to get back up
after a beating and come back stronger
than ever which is what he really needed
after the ill-fated fight against
crocodile
things uh that they didn't go too well
for luffy in his first battle against
crocodile the fight started off as a
back and forth exchange but
as the battle went on i personally felt
that the odds were getting more and more
stacked against our hero it all
culminated in him getting impaled in the
middle of ranting and being left for
dead
few can get back up after such a
demoralizing defeat but
if anyone's up for it it has to be the
one and only monkey d luffy
things do get more heated in their next
battle largely thanks to this stomping
that would have no doubt stuck in
luffy's mind for a long time
as a series is mainly known for its
masterful ability to swing between
comedic episodes and
really serious and dramatic arcs among
its more serious and impactful arc is
the fort davis arc
and this brief scuffle in my opinion is
the point when tensions truly rise in
this arc meeting jirocho at the cemetery
kintoki snaps upon seeing what happened
to othose he proceeds to attack with
reckless abandon this action forces
jirocho to release his sword and as you
typically know from anime the
rage-filled protagonist typically
doesn't come out on top in a fight
against the non-mooc especially one at
this point of an arc against a strong
opponent the subsequent battle saw
gintoki getting defeated handily prior
to the latter episodes episode 211
is probably the most emotionally intense
episode of the series and has become a
fan favorite just for this single moment
many people were caught off guard here
and you know what rightfully so
most of us would associate kaneki vs
jason being the crowning moment in tokyo
ghoul where kaneki finally embraces his
gaul site and beats jason to oblivion
what often gets overlooked is their
first encounter which put garneki in
that position to unleash his gaul side
in the first place
jason known as yamuri has his first
encounter with karneki during a raid
discovering his nature jason then
proceeds to be kaneki unconscious in
order to abduct
him the ride's far from ending for
kaneki as he then undergoes a lot of
torture both physically and
psychologically
this would soon open up the way to him
accepting his ghoul side and letting it
run loose at the show's climax
[Music]
whenever people from the berserk fandom
bring up guts
it's always in the form of some other
worldly admiration
and why wouldn't they as far as an anime
character goes
guts is by far one of the toughest and
most badass ones out there and his feats
in his series are nothing short of being
otherworldly that's not to say that
everything has gone his way though
you see there is this event called the
eclipse yes the eclipse where griffith
finally transcends and becomes femto
in this event we see guts at his lowest
in a surreal spectacle despite fighting
against and managing to eliminate a lot
of the demons
he eventually finds himself taken down
and forced to watch kaska
things would have been far worse had the
skull knight not interfered for all the
badass feats and character traits that
guts has
i don't think any of the characters have
fallen down in depths as low as he did
at this point in time
and there you go 10 times where things
didn't go too well for the protagonist
who says that heroes always win the day
in a medium like anime hey
these 10 moments prove otherwise and in
one way or another they've become a
permanent memory in the minds of people
watching these series
what other moments can you think of the
top of your head i'd love to hear from
you
if you enjoyed watching this video go
ahead and press that like button and
subscribe to my channel if you enjoy
anime content of this kind i'll see you
next time on
vinnie tube
[Music]